Rob it's really fun to walk around on
all the planets and check out some these
weird-ass creatures that we've been
finding the whole office has been
playing we found some really really dumb
stuff I want to show you the coolest
weirdest and dumbest animals in no man's
sky that we found in the last week I
can't wait not only can you get them but
you can name them as well which adds a
lot of fun to this whole process wolf
with receding hairline
now that's intentional faux hawk right
there oh this is a half deer yeah I
called this the butt outta here
oh you named it it's just basically a
head on an ass
whoa this is one of the coolest ones
I've seen he's got fins on his elbows
he's kind of a strange deer but a
gorilla upper half like a half deer yeah
[ __ ] frog majestic check out his walk
though he's one of the best walks trust
me he's like prancing with his front
arms but his back legs are like trying
to keep up my body's a little big my
head is too small
we've named him lime head uh I also
think he looks like a snow cone it's
funny huh I kind of think he looks like
a parakeet but like a parakeet that
dipped his head and some radioactive
fluid and then the rest of him is cow
why it looks like the spokesperson for
jack-in-the-box I haven't seen a lot of
six legged animals this one with us no
all right you don't need those back ones
at all they don't look like they're
gonna pick up on a mom like from an
evolution standpoint like yeah you need
those back way what those are the fake
legs in case it gets attacked by a
predator it's got extra it's got four
more yeah I mean look at the environment
it's filled with radiation you gotta go
tall he's got a hairball
whoa yeah this is a oh man this is just
like spore right when you get like these
random pieces and you kind of mash them
all together then you get something like
this bug head on a dinosaur tail that is
so ugly yet maybe like a deer ish front
cat kind of looks like he got his head
stuck in a beehive maybe his backs got
all these weird talons coming off of it
it's a very strange guy Oh
majestic hey it's just like they really
gave up when they got to the head God
just said moving on moving on I got a
lot of work to do oh I haven't seen a
lot underwater so I'm usually like the
very few creatures we've found
underwater as y-you look at the way they
swim because it doesn't look like they
should be moving the way they swim hmm
looks like some invisible guys shaking
them yeah pyramid heads yeah it's got a
real Silent Hill yeah yeah exactly yeah
they look like really strange I didn't
know what to name these because they're
so strange-looking I named them I don't
know that guy was easier that's
Christmas ornament
got some stones on him you really like
this guy yeah I enjoy him
whoa these are weird these are one of
the coolest things I found dragon-like
they got four heads oh man
they're wild wow this guy actually ran
into a wall yeah
is this proud of it got like a fly head
that is so weird-looking
that's so gross dinosaur body and like
elk legs his eyes are like at 800% he
can see you or his pupils
those are like jet he's like just pupil
oh he was trippin did I hit ya did not
see that coming weird right what the
[ __ ] it was like a cow with his ass way
too high in the air screw that torso
what is with Ali feet leg fingers oh
it's like a it's like a intense
ballerina don't ballerinas like learn
how to pivot on their toes that looks
really uncommon it's really upsetting
yeah it's like a cow if cows walked on
their fingers instead of on whose it is
hard time walking oh this one I think is
me I just want you to see there's
mushroom Lee's got like a face oh my god
smashed across my ha ha ha this oh my
god kill it that is what happens to you
when you die you go to hell you go to
hell and you get turned in one of those
where's his head this one's my favorite
Johnny Bravo is what I named him watch
yes just looks dumb as hell okay
you look super dumb and really excited
to mate well that's like the first legit
face I've seen it's too real it's a
little freaky yeah it's also listen I
want you here is mating call you must
not get any because that sounds really
awful
oh mama oh that's weak yeah ladies
gerbil face kind of looks like a lemur
face was he just grooming himself yeah
he's making sure he looks good that tail
sucks giant thing that's oh I fed him
and he gave me this item and it was
nothing oh nothing
it was nice to see you like it mama in
this game probably got like her legs
that looks like a normal aunt Oh like
come on right it's the most normal oh
he's dead now yeah he's dead
good yeah well that's about it I guess
way to end it on a high note those are
the coolest weirdest and the dumbest
things I found on this planet cool well
thanks for showing me uh you know as we
all progress in this pretty cool game I
more weird one people come back in
another compilation yeah I think you
could we could do this again cool well
thanks man yeah thank you guys